[Music]
homie look what I become
we're live oh we're going live right now
yeah so folks uh emergency podcast
yesterday I tweeted about it asking if
you guys won one everybody said yes
after what happened with the news
yesterday with Tate's arrest
we uh came together had a couple
meetings movable which is good and now
here we are doing this live podcast uh
meanwhile I I do want to start off with
this tweet just so everybody knows this
is a tweet
that uh was posted by Andrew Tate just
three hours ago at 5 30 a.m and he said
the Matrix send their agents and if you
don't know yet they got arrested last
night they got raided last night
and right after getting graded you know
a bunch of different people different uh
Twitter spaces a guy Mario neftal I
believe who does a phenomenal job with
these Twitter spaces
uh we were on there was a bunch of a few
hundred thousand people on the uh
Twitter space last night uh talking on
this issue and it was very very
interesting to see
the two different sides a group that was
super happy that this took place and a
group that was super devastated that
this took place anyways we're going to
talk about that today on the podcast
Adam Vinnie Malik AKA Robin house as
well what was your initial thought when
you saw this atom
I don't think anybody was shocked
because he's addressed these allegations
prior even the interview we did with
Tate he's
he was saying yeah they've they've
attempted to uh conspire against me the
Matrix the system and uh
specifically he addressed human
trafficking sex trafficking he addressed
this do you recall yeah and he's like
I've never held a woman against her will
right and this is
sort of the knock on him so the the
people like I don't know how much Tate
is worth allegedly you know he says
hundreds of millions there's a billions
like I mean if you've got a casino
you're doing well I don't know uh his
net worth I I I have an inkling that
it's a pretty high amount but I think a
lot of people think it's a lot higher
than it actually is regardless I think
he's obviously success successful guy
it's no secret
that he has made his money from doing
cam girls video girls web girls and he
tells the story of well there's girls
that work with me and they make 10 grand
a month let's say I take five they take
five all right so that's the split 50
50. if they try to go do it on their own
they go make two thousand dollars and
they get to keep a hundred percent of it
yeah so what do you want to do baby you
want to come work for me and I keep half
the money and you still make more money
or you want to go do it on your uh do it
go do it on your own and essentially
that was his business model and I'm sure
it did well I mean we've seen what
happens with the rise of only fans and
sex workers online and by the way that's
there's nothing illegal about that
nothing as far as I know
um
where I think it gets into murky Waters
is you know everything that goes with
the metoo movement believe all women
it's like all it takes is for like one
girl to say one wrong thing and next
thing you know everyone's believing it
so
here I guess is my point I I I I'm by
the way we're going to go through a lot
of different things Greta we're going to
talk about the tweets the stories what
happened we're going to read all of that
but that's what I learned is right there
Pat don't mess with Greta Thunder she is
an OG first of all I don't think it's
her but her first her first one was you
know small dick whatever.com today's
tweet she goes that's what you get let
me go through it why do I actually go
through go show the Tweet go up a little
bit that's her first one right no no go
go this is the very first tweet yeah so
okay hello Greta I'm 30 I have 33 cars
my Bugatti is this my two Ferraris are
this this is just the start please
provide your email address so I can send
you a complete list of my car collection
and their respective enormous emissions
by the way look at how many likes it
gets go a little lower you get so many
lives 150 million views yeah look how
many likes 213 000 okay but now watch
the opposite side now gold regretta's
response she says yes please don't like
me email me at smalldickenergy
getalife.com now see how many likes this
one gets go down
uh 3.4 million likes 242 million views
okay you got admit that was kind of
funny yeah that is but by the way I
don't think that she's the one being
like got him she's like a marketing she
hasn't put it together same thing that
Trump like remember we talked about last
time she has the same person that Trump
had no no no no no I don't know about
that I think Trump is a marketer I think
she is getting help there's a big
difference he's a marketer for sure
anyways he responds back with a video do
you guys see the video where he's like
hey give me the pizza make sure the box
is not recycled or whatever you don't
need to play it okay but it's a very
funny video and you know he's just being
the troll that he is and having fun with
her yeah very entertaining on what he
does and then I believe she did another
tweet this morning if you want to go to
her tweet this morning this is what
happens when you don't recycle your
pizza boxes come on and this is just
fighting that one yeah but is that so
but do you think you think it's true
though Pat that that's how because I
guess the Romanian police the
authorities wanted to find out if he was
in Romania and out of all things the
pizza box stop
but what people are saying is they found
him because of the pizza he ordered in
Romania from a local pizza shop with the
logo 25 or whatever it's on that and
that's how they found you know him to go
to his place that's what they're saying
okay that's what they're saying okay but
let's just unpack that what does that I
mean he we all know he lives at this
compound in Romania yes he's very vocal
about it he lives there with his brother
he talks about it all the time he's in
the room he films all his videos and
yeah it doesn't take a [__] Pizza
sleuth to figure that out is all I'm
saying he lives there yeah right talk
about pizza games like homie he lives
there well here's my here's my question
do you guys think it was like uh like
they were just waiting because what I
took away from this is like there's only
so many times that you could poke a bear
so it's going to turn around and bite
your ass this is like a organized effort
to be like oh we got him and I'll do
like you said it takes one girl and mind
you all it takes is one girl for the
Matrix people to get to and say listen
we're gonna give you some money you just
yeah you hung out with them just say
this and he's going down no doubt can we
read can we read the story if you want
to pull up the story just to read it and
then the news just dropped right now
from Yahoo PA media I'll text you as
well to read uh but let's read the first
story that was broke now the first story
that broke yeah want me to read it yeah
go for it
arrested in police raid as part of human
trafficking investigation controversial
kickboxer Andrew Tate and his younger
brother Tristan he also was arrested by
the way we're handcuffed and led Away by
Romanian police following a raid on
their luxury Villa on Thursday
controversial
kickboxing social media is arrested
remaining suspicion of human trafficking
rape and forming an organized crime
group a handcuffed Tate 36 Who Rose the
famous here for a sexist and
misogynistic views you see what they're
doing out there of course
was
film being led up from his luxury Villa
by police following a raid on Thursday
his younger brother Tristan 34 was also
arrested along with two other suspects
so there's four in total being held for
24 hours in Bucharest and I think that's
where we pick up they've been held for
24 hours and I believe
he's out now yeah well that's uh uh do
you have the clip I sent you play the
clip of him uh if you have the clip on
him getting arrested play that first and
then go play the clip of him getting out
so play the clip of him getting arrested
uh let's see if you have you have it
somewhere on here
there you go okay
turn on the audio
yeah there you go
oh they really set this up yeah so SWAT
came in that's the primary version of
SWAT and he wasn't handcuffed by the way
I don't know if they have handcuffs in
Romania I think he was no he wasn't he
got his brother was definitely
handcuffed doing the whole try the power
V yeah he had to come out with the parts
you're moving yeah
and go
I actually like this
nice guy
[Music]
medieval weapons
well you know those guys are stealing
[__] at the house
okay now play the one of them getting
out this morning by the way when he was
getting arrested I only heard uh him say
one thing I was being led into the car
he said the Matrix sent their agents
yeah that's correct that's it
and that's him right there
so that's the that's the next one of
them getting out okay so let me let me
if you can go to Twitter go to my the
last tweet I posted
um
so yesterday while this is going on
we're in meetings I'm doing zooms I'm
doing a bunch of different things people
are texting me your boy got down and you
know your boy they took him down all
this I'm like listen keep going keep
going keep going keep going keep going
uh oh one more one more one right there
click on that one right there click on
that one zoom in a little bit okay I
said don't know exactly the details of
uh Tate's arrest but here's what I do
know a day after he publicly calls out
one of Wok's Heroes Greta thundberg they
rate his place strange timing meanwhile
we haven't seen anyone from Epstein's
list arrested weird strange now go to
the bottom
at the bottom I say he's loud he pushes
the envelope he frustrates the left he
points at hypocrisy he's duplicating
young men to do the same having said
that if they committed a crime the
proper agencies will do what they need
to do till then innocent till proven
guilty
so then then I get invited on this
Twitter spaces with again the guy Mario
nufaul I think he does a fantastic job
as a host and I'm on there
and he says so Patrick you've
interviewed with him you've spent many
hours with them how is he how is he on
camera how is he off camera I said quite
frankly I locked him more off camera
than on camera and I like them on camera
yeah I just like them more off camera I
would agree he says so what do you have
to say about you know all the stuff
that's coming out I said here's here's a
couple things you have to be very
careful with
first thing you have to be very careful
with is
I said as a father anytime the school
calls me telling me what my son did
wrong my natural inclination is to say
what my son would never do something
exactly until I talk to him I'm like oh
shoot you know he yeah
so so and by the way you know that it
ought to be that way but you know
Parents Ought To You know have a a
certain level of loyalty and belief in
their kids you know if I get a call from
somebody saying what you did something
and I'm getting a call and I'm talking
to the person you're not going to have a
conversation and then I'm going to sit
there and say listen you know it is what
it is let's wait to see what's going on
regardless of what it is we have to know
two things both can be right one I was
going to Bible study years ago when I'm
an atheist and this guy's trying to
convert me I'm like listen you're not
going to do it 25 years I've been an
Atheist you can convert me and I told
him I said look I've been to churches
I've seen pastors do this I've seen
pastors take advantage of you know
members rip them off with money
marriages what they were doing on the
side smoking weed doing drugs having sex
and then they're claiming up they're on
stage that they're so mighty he says
here's a rule number one about if you
want to have a relationship with the man
upstairs if it's horizontal you'll
always be disappointed if it's vertical
you'll never be disappointed I said
explain that to me he says people are
going to let you down okay everybody is
you've let down your kids you've done
you've let down your parents you've let
me not that time I don't have kids but
he's saying you've let down your parents
you know your parents have let you down
your sisters let you down you've let her
down your friends all this stuff none of
us walk on water okay just hope you
don't make the big mistakes but we don't
walk on water we all make mistakes
don't be surprised if a hero disappoints
you that's one so years after that I'm
working at this church this one a Syrian
guy comes to me they want to create an
Assyrian part of this church I want to
mention the guy's name and he says man I
will kiss the pastor's feet he's this
he's that he's saying this in front of
30th Series in this one guy's house
Wilson and I said listen never ever put
that much pressure on a man to be
perfect because he's gonna fall never
give that much you know love and
attention and accolades to human being
give him love give him respect but
you're talking as if he's God and he
can't make any mistakes he says he can't
he's never going to make mistakes and
say listen I don't want that kind of
person I said I'm not I can't help you
guys out with this request that you have
bring it to to today okay you know you
have to know the people who really
support this guy they don't think he can
do anything wrong and that's unfair to
him and it's managing too much
expectations for yourself the other side
the people who can't stand like on
yesterday's Twitter spaces one Romanian
lawyer got on he says they're not going
to let him be bailed down he's not going
to get out they're probably going to do
15 to 20 years and another guy comes and
he should go to jail and another you
should go to jail he's going to go to
jail do you realize what he does this is
unfair all this stuff that they're
saying about what's going on with this
right people by the end of yesterday's
Twitter spaces everybody said this guy's
going to jail for 15 to 20 years okay so
that's what they believe they believe
These Guys these are a Romanian lawyer
got him oh wow a Romanian lawyer got on
and said hey here's what's going on the
Romanian lawyer also said something I
was pretty fascinating but the people
who don't like him let's not get it
twisted a girl yesterday tweets at me
some comedian Nicole something I don't
even know what her last name is but she
tweets at me and she says you're you're
this and you're dead you're exactly this
I said listen the difference between me
and you is your emotional and your speak
speaking factual like this is going to
happen
I'm being logical and paranoid that's
the only difference I said you're doing
this I'm doing that okay and you know so
so the people that are happy that he got
arrested you know what crowd they're a
part of you know why you know they're
celebrating whatever they're celebrating
having said that let's set that aside
let's set those two aside this is the
most important point to be thinking
about okay that's the most important
point to be thinking about if he
committed to Crime he committed the
crime okay I don't know all the rules
and regulations I don't know you know
Cardone got on and he says well I don't
know anybody that does all the right
business and has six different uh
passports why do you need to have six
different passports and Etc et cetera
okay it's a valid point why do you need
six different passports maybe that's
normal in Europe maybe that's how he
gets around maybe it's a valuable thing
to have passports I know billionaires
that have multiple passports maybe not
six but I do know people that have two
or three passports in that area it's
actually very normal for somebody to
have don't forget multiple passports
not so subtly address the fact that his
father may or may not have worked for
the CIA yeah yeah right yeah so so but
here's the part man we were doing a
video
a month ago in generational wealth
remember when the whole thing was on my
generation was generation one of the
things we we realized is the Vanderbilts
lost their wealth they were the richest
people in the world they lost their
wealth within two generations think
about that damn you're worth a few
hundred billion dollars the money's lost
within two generations but the Medici
family and the Rothschild family has
kept the wealth in the power for many
many years you know what rule those guys
follow one basic rule don't be loud yeah
do not be loud don't call out the
establishment don't be too opinionated
stay low-key keep a low profile you
don't see a Rothschild getting on TV
giving their opinions running a podcast
you don't see a Medici family running
the top podcast in the world now having
said that the Medici and the Rothschild
is playing a different game right
they're in they're indirectly part of
the establishment of course because they
have by global Elites exactly
definitions so so the global so for
fortade to go out and and you keep
calling out the heroes of the left over
and over and over and over again you're
taking the ultimate ultimate risk this
means the speed to stardom is very very
quickly but the fall could also be very
very quickly by these guys trying to
manipulate and take you down FYI one of
the corruptest countries in the world is
Romania you know how many people
messaged me yesterday from Romania
listen this place is corrupt that lawyer
on the Twitter spaces yesterday said the
following
he said everything in Romania is about
money everything so if you want to buy
them out to get out you can do it if
other countries want to buy Romania they
can do it wow if other countries want to
call Romania to say hey man you guys got
to get this thing scored away or else
we're not going to give you the support
or we're not going to give you this you
have to do it because Romaine who's
Romania is it a top 20 Empire is it a
top 50 Empire nobody thinks about
Romania as one of the most powerful
empires in the world that everybody
wants to have a relationship with yeah
this ain't Rome no yeah this is
definitely Romania so meaning if a place
like Romania can be bought to take a guy
like this down that is very possible not
saying that's what happened that's very
possible then last but not least I get a
message this morning from a guy that's
very very connected in uh the the the
what's the word I'm looking for he's
very connected in law and um
FBI PD you know all the Department of
Justice extremely qualified God I don't
want to give exactly what his job is
because you know who it is okay he said
the following I saw the interviews last
night keep this in mind if you talk to
him they have to have probable cause to
do the war to do these warrants the
excuse that somebody made a complaint an
anonymous complaint
uh at that and they send a SWAT team to
his house as [__] even though it's
Romania they still have laws in the U.S
embassy uh and the U.S embassy was
involved I think the embassy put them up
to it he needs to find out where the
hell and uh complain from there anyways
meaning he's trying to say it's all they
all work together meaning this this is
not accidental to do the warrant maybe
there is a probable cause for it but
also at the same time U.S embassy was
involved to go on and taking him down so
it's a it's a very strange situation
going on with this year so it's not just
a one-sided story there's a lot of
different sides to it but everybody
jumped to conclusions celebrating this
guy getting arrested it was like their
New Year's came five days before three
days before with this guy getting
arrested
it reminds you of that like uh John
Gotti when he was out and everybody was
telling him all the conciliarities
they're all like listen you're poking at
the wrong he's like shut up he's like
we're not supposed to be out you know
it's a it's a secret thing you know I
mean like he's exactly that situation
with him it's like you poked it you
poked it just kind of disappear you
can't keep bothering yo you can't keep
messing with governments and they're not
going to come after your ass that's this
is a prime example well of the same [__]
with Gotti a couple thoughts
um
a famous story that I always revisit
with you that you said I don't know who
you were meeting with you were meeting
with some billionaire and you had a you
had a business idea for this billionaire
and I think condescendingly but also
like affectionately it was like Pat
there's two types of people in this
world there's the person who's trying to
make their first billion and the person
that's already made their billions the
difference between us is I'm just trying
to keep my money aka the medicis the
Rothschilds these types of people you're
the first type of person good luck on
your endeavors I'm gonna keep doing me
right essentially investing in stocks or
investing in bonds essentially if you
want to put it that way let's not forget
nobody knew Tate one year ago
okay unless you're a kickboxer guy yeah
nobody knew Tate whatsoever okay so he's
essentially working on his first billion
if you know what I mean so you know you
in today's society whether you're good
bad up or down it's all about views it's
all about eyeballs it's all about status
so he's trying to make a name for
himself the problem is what this is kind
of akin to is like we all read Greek
mythology as a kid
Icarus you know he flew a little too
close to the Sun and he got burned
um regarding I think Romania if I may
address that
um
I had a conversation with a buddy who
lives in Colombia
it was uh we were hanging out yesterday
I go Hey listen
what happened to innocent until proven
guilty he goes south
you live in America that's a real sweet
idea in Colombia it's guilty until
proven innocent like he told the story
of a buddy who got his house taken away
from the government and it's taken 10
years of legal nonsense to try to get
his house back that he's entitled to so
I don't know the framework in Romania
but something tells me in corrupt
countries you can kind of just do what
you want to do yeah bro Money Talks the
one thing I will say about Romania do
you think this is a good look or a bad
look for the country of Romania I would
argue that nobody has done more to help
tourism and to make Romania popular as
it is now than Tate if Tate didn't live
in Romania if he lived in Croatia if he
lived in Serbia if he lived in somewhere
in Russia nobody would be talking about
Romania of course like in a in and he's
said only good things about Romania I
come here it's a Christian country yes
it's corrupt but everywhere it's
corrupted this difference is you can pay
people off here I I there's nice people
people nice women like it's it's like
almost done the exact same thing that
Borah did for Kazakhstan yeah nobody
know the Kazakhstan before but the
difference is
Borah kind of yeah yeah uh Tate did good
things for Romania we're talking about
Romania oh he has a casino there you
know how much money the the with taxes
that they're gonna get for the country
are you crazy bro yeah so he's um
I don't know look I here's what I
actually want to say you talked about
like the people that love Tate they're
coming to his defense the people that
hate Tate are just jumping on it by the
way now for whether it's me whether it's
you whether it's anybody out there
listening now is the easiest time ever
to [__] on Tate the pilot I knew it he's
a scumbag like but
like now is actually where you show
conviction and actually show friendship
and actually show someone you know what
you respect so for me I'm not believing
any of this nonsense I'm gonna I'm gonna
stand by my innocent until proven guilty
and I'm we've had a great time with Tate
I have nothing but good things to say
about Tate are there going to be some
things we disagree upon sure I disagree
with you you're one of my best friends
you know same with Pat but I'm not
believing any of this nonsense I I again
innocent until proven guilt tell up the
story I just texted you rob let's read
that reuter story that just came out an
hour ago I agree with you Adam push for
sure
oh by the way one other very credible
lady got on yesterday saying uh uh
what's her name Liza Eliza something
like that okay let me read this article
that I'll tell you what she said
ex-kickboxer Andrew rape and human
traffic case okay go down all right so
Romanian prosecutors as a Bucharest
court on Friday to extend detention on
dendro take 30 days uh but after the
divisive internet personality was
arrested on suspicion of human
trafficking right here take a former
kickboxer uh and his brother Tate okay
got that and anti-organized crime
prosecutors have notified the rights and
Liberties judge with the Bucharest court
with the proposal to remand the four
suspects for 30 days the brothers
declined to comment on Thursday but the
lawyer confirmed they had been this
detained prosecutors said the Tate
Brothers have been under criminal
investigation since April the four
suspects appeared to have created an
organized crime group with the purpose
of recruiting housing and exploiting
women by forcing them to create
pornographic content meant to be seen on
Specialized websites for must go a
little lower
keep going keep going keep going uh
prosecutors said they would have gained
the uh important sums of money
prosecutors said they found six women
who had been sexually exploited by the
suspect's Tate gained notoriety for
misogynistic comments and hate speech he
said the women are partially responsible
for being raped and they belonged to men
a number of social media platforms
banded including Twitter but his account
here became active no again November
after the platform was taken over by
Elon Musk in one of his tweets following
his return to platform uh said he was
flying to California to tell musk he was
a legend Tate appeared to have sent a
tweet on Friday suggesting get access to
his phone and social media while in
custody early this week the British
national was told to get a life by
climate activist Greta thundberg on
Twitter okay we know that whole story
how this thing takes uh takes place but
so there are six so one of these girls
uh uh who was on the uh Twitter spaces
yesterday said the following she says
look
you have to keep in mind that I've been
dealing with one of the uh I've been
dealing with one of the uh individuals
that's uh uh making these claims women
that's making these claims uh since
summer about uh that she was taking
advantage of and I've been working with
her since April or May this lady said I
said I can't give you all the details I
can't say anything I can't do this I
can't do that because I'm you know I'm
representing her I'm helping her out but
this is real they have been doing this
and the phrase that was constantly being
used yesterday is the following phrase
called the lover boy allegation I don't
know if you're familiar with the lover
boy allegation pull up lover boy
allegation type in lover boy allegation
which uh lover boy human okay right
there the first one yeah okay so uh zoom
in so we can read it in so lover boys or
Romeo pimps are human traffickers who
usually operate by trying to make young
girls or boys fall in love with them
sometimes they manipulate young people
in other ways once they have victims
under their influence they exploit them
for instance in sex industry lover boy
method changing due to internet and
social media traditionally Loverboy
seduces young vulnerable girls and boys
over a lengthy period of time in order
to exploit them sexually later on this
practice is being used less and less
nowadays lover boys Resort more quickly
and frequently to threatening their
victims using blackmail and violence the
internet and social media are playing an
increasing role in this phenomenon for
instance social media provides lover
boys with much greater scope for
establishing contact with victims and
gathering information about vulnerable
boys and girls this makes it easier for
them to force their young victims into
the sex industry so that is the
methodology they're saying they used
yeah well uh if I may the definite like
the lover like listen I go out in South
Beach I have friends who are
good-looking dudes lover boys like pimp
type dudes what they're describing are
sociopaths and criminals yeah okay since
when is being a good-looking Suave
methodical dude a bad thing I think
that's actually a good thing so they're
they're kind of copying and pasting and
and a a a nice name over actually a very
criminal intensive type of description
so I don't know this lover boy thing
have you guys seen have you go on
anything that Dan bilzerian's doing it's
gone go on his Instagram it's Dan
Bilzerian Pat with like 50 of the
hottest and he's just in the back
chilling he just lover boy lover boy I
mean like obviously and mind you these
girls are getting the notoriety they're
with them they're on Instagram all these
girls have a massive following
everywhere everybody's getting paid he's
the like Adam said lover boy he's the
Playboy and it's an image but like I
said Pat the it's all I'm not a consumer
Jersey guy but it's all kahoots
everybody if the U.S embassy is involved
and they go bro go in there get the
cameras record it and mind you win this
hit hat it hit every all my
notifications
it's a it's a it's an effort by
everybody all together to try to knock
this guy down because they mess with
them let me tell you something about
these lover boys okay whatever this is
there's exceptions and there are rules
okay let's talk about the rule because
obviously we can go to exceptions if
you're Dan Bilzerian if you're Andrew
Tate for example if you're Leonardo
DiCaprio if you're Matthew McConaughey
you're George Clooney you don't need a
resort to this type of [__] nonsense
you have girls throwing themselves at
you yeah you don't need to induce you
don't need a drug you don't need to like
manipulate you get what you want now the
exceptions your [__] scumbag like
Bill Cosby or Harvey Weinstein those are
the exceptions but if you're an
exceptional dude or you're a high due to
man of status you don't need to resort
to these types of measures it's just
something you don't need to do as a dude
yeah the worst dudes out there are the
guys that can't get laid they get no
attention from girls got nothing going
on for them those are the sociopaths you
need to look out for yeah those are the
rapists those are the criminals I'm not
buying this [__] I mean like you
said is that he's lucky that it is
Romania he has he has money bro he's not
going to go to jail for for I don't
think he's gonna go to jail at all yeah
but that's the problem because I know
Pat here the RICO thing that Giuliani
and them did is that now think about
this if he has somebody in his crew that
was being shady does he get in trouble
so so what they're what they're one of
the things you guys said a lot of
different things here so I want to make
sure we address this lover boy Hugh
Hefner was a lover boy exactly number
one the ultimate lover boy guy you don't
you don't think he had accusations of
course he had women still to this day
accusing him of like holding them
hostile he did but the only difference
is he didn't call out climate change act
he didn't call out exactly the left he
didn't call out any of this stuff so
there's a there's a rule of thumb if you
go after the establishment be ready if
you go after the establishment be ready
especially the louder You Are by the way
there are only a few people loud enough
to go after the establishment one of the
guys today that's super loud is number
one is musk and Tate's in the top ten of
the loudest against establishment we
know what happened when Trump went after
the establishment we're seeing what's
going on with musk going after
establishment we're seeing what he went
after the establishment those are a
couple things got to be careful with
here's the part about what you just said
one of the claims is what they're trying
to do okay is you know how a lot of
times like well how come he doesn't come
to us I don't want to come to us I don't
want to come to us I don't want to come
to us one of the claims that one of the
lawyers made is they're trying to use
this to bring them to U.S courts to get
him to be seen guilty this is an outcome
of trying to bring him here extra
condition yes to bring him here and have
the U.S courts hold them accountable
okay because who is he calling out if
you were to take out at 196 countries or
so that we have give or take what
country does he call out the most U.S
not is there even a western Society not
culture Global Western Society is the
first 100 tree he calls out non-stop
he's constantly calling out okay and
what's he calling out about the Western
Society like making men into like making
a systems and he's basically saying that
you know when you want to come and let's
say take over country you got to take
the men get the men out make them
feminine and he's just calling out all
the woke [__] who you know the the woke
folks don't want to hear that the left
folks don't want to hear that that's not
women also don't want to no no no I'm
telling you yesterday the amount of uh
uh DMS that I got I've never gotten DMs
like this you piece of [__] do you think
by the way I might as well die in the
same nonsense no you know I can't
believe you said this and I can't
believe you said that to me that's not
triple uh uh you know typical protocol
where people messaging and stuff like
that but to defend him he's that much of
a trigger to the left because Greta
don't forget that that post that tweet
by her gut couple hundred million views
on Twitter and this is under musk that
thing got a couple hundred million views
under Twitter what does that tell you
she's got a following of course she's
got influence people actually want to
sit there and believe that she's right
and by the way thank God she's 19 years
old because some people to come back and
said you're going after minor right yeah
but she's 19 years old so it's not like
she's a we all know her as 12 years old
or 15 years old she's no longer 15 years
old she's 19 years old today so yeah
they're trying to bring him to the
states to that's what a lot of people
said they're trying to bring them out
here but we'll see here's where I think
Tate message Gets Lost in Translation so
when we sat with him I said what's the
number one reason you thought you were
canceled he goes I already know I
already know because I asked it is it
masculinity is it toxic masculinity
chauvinism is it calling out the system
is it calling out the Matrix is it male
self-improvement he's like I already
know uh the reason I got canceled is
because I call out the establishment I
call out the Matrix they don't want to
hear what I have to say but if you talk
about text messaging
um I believe there's three major
um
themes that he talks about so number one
is he's called out the Matrix and the
system and everything in the global
Elite that comes with that cool Fair we
just addressed that number two is what
he's labeled as a misogynist or a
chauvinist and toxic masculinity and
that's kind of how he's labeled like if
you look at any article out there any
headline it's male chauvinist Andrew
Tate you know toxic masculinity Andrew
Tate and that's kind of what he's framed
as but if you actually peel back the
onion and you actually listen to what
Tate's saying and not taking it little
sound bites all he's talking about at
the end of the day is male
self-improvement and that's essentially
everything that we stand for here at
valuetainment that's everything that we
that I talk about here is no matter what
you're doing in life as a man there's
always room for self-improvement
personal responsibility being positive
whether that's being Stronger Faster
cooler wealthy or dope or sexier
everything is about status okay so when
it comes to self-improvement here I'm
gonna go on a little rant for a second
the the number one thing that a man can
have is status there's three types of
status that a man can reach there's
number one wealth okay and everything
that comes with wealth money success
ambition your network everything that
you collect resources that's number one
part of status number two is
attractiveness as a man status so
meaning you're good looking you're in
shape you're you're you're Suave you're
you
um you dress well like Jordan Peterson
talks about dressing in suits and
looking like a man so that is
attractiveness women obviously like
dudes with six packs and most like
that's part of that and then the third
one is having game now everyone there's
different types of game out there that
can improve your status so whether it's
you're you're funny you're a comedian
you're clever you're witty you
um you're romantic you like you're kind
whatever it is that's your game now
here's the deal
if you're in the top 10 of any of those
three categories you will get women and
you and women will come to you what do I
mean if you've got a ton of money I
don't care if you look like you know
we've seen Jeff Bezos yeah women are
going to be attracted to number two if
you're an attractive guy you're in shape
you're a good looking dude like that's
done like no matter how much money you
have you're gonna get women if you've
got game whether you're a funny comedian
or whether you're a swap dude a romantic
whatever it is whatever your skill set
is if you're in the top 10 of any of
those three categories you'll get women
now to put this all together like date
would do he would say keep working on
all three make your money work your ass
out improve your game learn how to talk
to women you know famously in the red
pill Community what he's a part of it's
money muscles game and hold frame so
again back to my initial Point yes he
talks about the system and he talks
about people label him as a misogynist
and a and a toxic masculinity but the
end of the day I think the reason that
he's resonated with so many dudes he's
like nobody's coming to save you bro
nobody's walking in this door you need
to do it yourself keep improving keep
working out work out strategize out and
prove Outlast and that's his messaging
but nobody wants to talk about that so
yeah it is his messaging but at the same
time by the way Elon Musk just tweeted
something right now if you want to pull
it up he just said if I what if I told
you the only way to escape the matrix is
to unlearn everything that you have been
taught and rebuild your entire belief
system based on critical thought and
Analysis and it's a picture from the
Matrix he just posted this 10 minutes
ago so what's he saying is he kind of
following what's going on is he kind of
uh following the stories of what's going
on I do want to show something about
what cardi B said yesterday pull up the
Tweet about cardi B but by the way while
we're talking about the Matrix do you
know who the number one most viral
person in the world could be if he
wanted to take the mantle Keanu Reeves
yeah of course with everything that
we're talking about the system The
Matrix and red pill and blue pill that's
a good point if Keanu Reeves said listen
I'm not I'm not doing John Wick anymore
I don't know whatever movies I don't
watch movies Bill and Ted's bogus
Adventure part four if he's like oh you
want to talk about the Matrix let me
tell you something yeah Keanu Reeves
would be the most searched man in the
world so this is what cardi B just said
yesterday she said well well well you
know about Andrew Tate and his brother
being arrested right cardi B now here
here's here's the crazy part while she's
saying this okay here's a crazy part
while she's saying this Rob pull up this
article from CNN I just sent you Hardy B
pull up the article from CNN I just
literally I just texted it to you pull
that one up I love what you said about
cardi B yeah let's talk about that but I
want you to see this here real quick
right after what she just said so this
is a story from CNN cardi B admits to
drugging Robin men years ago admits
admitted admitted it so do you have the
whole story do you have the whole story
to click on it like the one I sent you
or uh um because Pat this is the one
where she's she's and she's admitting
when she was stripping that she would
literally take guys out yeah drug them
yeah drug them and then Rob the [__] out
of them and you have no idea as he's
looking for a pet I posted uh something
about this you should see the the the
the people coming after me on Instagram
where they were like hey you weren't in
her life you don't know what she was
going through in that moment I go what
the heck I don't know what it's like to
be a stripper yeah yeah no not even that
and then and then Pat just recently she
does a video in her car she's like guess
what if my man cheats on me you know
what I'm gonna do I'm like I'm gonna
grab a girl we're gonna take him out I'm
gonna get him all drugs on Percocets
we're gonna go and have a threesome but
she's not gonna be a girl it's gonna be
a guy a [__] and then guess what haha
we got you this is cardi B this is her
you're a good time to drug the robin so
go a little closer today cardi B took on
Instagram to contextualize and express
regret for a claim she made in a video
from three years ago in the resurface
Instagram live video the rapper claimed
that during her days as a stripper she
lured men to a hotel rooms for sex but
then drugged them and robbed them
instead I'm a part of hip-hop culture
where you can talk about where you came
from talk about the wrong things you've
done and where you are she wrote in a
note on Instagram and it's true she
hardly uh the first rapper had to have a
criminal pasta there are rappers that
glorify murder violence drugs and
robbing crimes they feel they had to do
to survive I never glorified the things
I brought up in the live in that live I
never put up those things in the music
because I'm not proud of it and felt
responsibly not too glorified I mean
there was a movie made about her by the
way you guys the JLo played you don't
remember the movie that James last two
years yeah so she was I mean that she's
in it yeah she's in the movie and and
partly that's her story it's partly her
story but here's the thing card to be no
one is saying that you know the hip-hop
culture the past we don't understand we
all listen to the similar type of
hip-hop music all people are saying is
the following
you don't earn the right to say this
because you're a hypocrite that's the
only reason nothing more nothing less
you sound like a hypocrite as if
somebody that walked on water and you
got up to where you are today by playing
some of those games if not worse and you
admitted to it
this man's being accused of it now
whether he did it or not the courts are
going to do their part but this is where
you lose some credibility when you're
saying what you're saying well the no
one of the major messages that Tate
talks about is is this new wave
feminism okay so I think we can all
agree I mean there's been like three
waves of feminism it was the first wave
feminism where like women's suffrage
right to vote of course who wouldn't
want that second wave feminism is right
like you know right to work be in the
workplace not get sexually harassed
totally makes sense this new wave third
wave feminism I'm a boss babe like I
Don't Need No Man like the cardi B WAP
whole situation well I mean he calls
these people out left and right yeah and
that there's no wonder that the cardi
B's of the world yeah so I I don't know
if that article was a misspelling that
instead of rapper it actually wrote
Raper because what she's done in her
past is but he's calling out this these
high body count hoe ass [__] women who
are being apostolized by new woke
feminists like I can have sex with as
many men as I want there's no
repercussions for my actions I can do
what I want to do it's like these are
the examples that they're setting for
women today
morbidly obese people like lizard
they're like she's a hero yeah she has
courage
yeah she's literally she's got diabetics
yeah yeah and and then and it goes to my
other point too it's like Pat mind you
this cardi B and this has been out for a
long long time she's the same girl that
sat down with the uh with Joe Biden they
interviewed like they were like you know
what let's use her to get votes they
don't give a [__] just like Bernie
Sanders too think about this Bernie
Sanders and the president of the United
States sat down and had a real
one-on-one with cardi B an openly
drugging module if there's any guys out
there that were drugged or Rabbi come
forward because if she did it for you
please come say something believe oh man
believe me all drugged men like [__]
they use her think about it they use her
to get the minority vote and they don't
give a [__] she doesn't give a damn
you hypocrite yeah I mean look to me you
did what you did you made your money you
know just as the mindset of a
Libertarian is do what you got to do to
make your money don't break the law
don't do anything to make your money but
she made her money breaking a lot any of
that stuff if she got caught doing that
that is a rape that you're taking
advantage of not necessarily rape that's
called robbery you're stealing money
from people yeah you can go to jail for
that but she's forgiven so again all of
this goes back to a guy called out
the BS on the establishment and they're
not happy about it and they got to take
them down it's that simple there's calls
that are saying this guy's getting
louder and louder and louder stop him
now before he gets more momentum here's
the kicker okay here's the kicker let's
let's look at some options let's look at
some some things that people are saying
is going on one
some are saying what if this whole thing
was a setup because this guy's doing it
intentionally knowing the amount of
eyeballs he's going to be getting what
if this whole thing was a publicity
stunt like I don't know if you guys saw
three days ago Pierce Morgan's Twitter
account came out and said Andrew Tate
just died did you see this or no okay go
to Andrew Tate Pierce Morgan died but I
wouldn't be shocked if Tate much like
Elon Musk had to put out a tweet that
says
so go to that tweet right there okay
what does this say breaking news Andrew
Tate has been shot uh found shot dead in
Dubai Mrs Morgan tweeted this but but
here's what the point is somebody broke
into his account okay and and Pierce
Morgan accidentally so anyway somebody
took over his account and did this and
Andrew Tates is hard to kill right so
who that's the one story but Steven
Seagal by the way well Pat you said I
think when you walked into there was
three levels of Heap and Andrew Taylor
said this live he said there's three
ways to get you out of the Matrix they
they cancel you they did one part number
two they put you in jail and he goes the
third part and he goes this is the scary
part is they kill your ass you fall you
have a heart attack some a plane crashes
so he's he's he has strike two there's
one more striking like you said like
when when is enough when is the point
Pat that you say okay I'm gonna shut up
or do you think he's so Die Hard really
for the people just like Elon doing what
he's doing that he's like I don't give a
[__] I'm gonna ride this wave to the end
what do you think where do you think
he's at I think he's a True Believer I
don't think he's you know because if if
you want to make if it's just purely
about money you don't do what he's doing
there's other ways to make money no if
it's just purely about money there's
easier ways to make money without being
a Target he is a True Believer of what
he believes in doesn't mean you have to
agree with it but he's not spewing out
stuff that he doesn't believe in now
some of this stuff is marketing some of
it is a Showmanship he's an incredible
showman uh he's a he's the combination
of a great communicator great
Storyteller great troll great showman
and a True Believer combined all in one
which is an unreal combination there are
people that tell great stories but
here's how they talk so Vinnie yeah six
o'clock in the morning yeah they went in
when they opened the door what happened
they saw Three Lions one of them winked
at them the other one had to go to the
bathroom oh [__] the third one was
missing its mom all of a sudden in the
back there was three rats
yeah but but this is
Bam you know so it's like yeah so he's
doing that and then he's mocking them
he's mocking the powerful people look
it's
[Music]
you cannot be surprised when you bully
the bully there are levels to bullies
okay you know it's the lowest level
bullying what's the lowest level bully
internet no no what's the low guy think
about this in your life picking on weak
people and then what's the lowest level
bully
picking on like the weakest what's the
fastest way to filter out somebody
that's a low-level bully to filter them
out yeah how do you how do you feel
let's go through different levels of
bullies okay okay lowest level of bully
is what what's the lowest level on your
names I know I know so how do you and I
categorize how strong of a bully
disguise what's the first thing you do
to a bully to find out if this guy's a
real bully you stop to him you step to
him if they back down what were they
they're the lowest level bullies
what's the second level bully that if
you do stuff to him the fight they're
going to fight you okay if you step to
them and they fight and they'll actually
fight you yeah okay and then if at the
end of the fight
you maybe got your ass beat yeah by the
bully but you were not willing to stop
fighting and he finally said listen I
got respect for you you're bloody but
he's got a couple shots you got in as
well he whooped your ass yeah it's like
I respect you listen man I'll just let's
just kind of respect
but don't mess with me right he still
stays bullied but now he knows yeah so
he's still a bully yeah okay the Third
Kind of bully is what the beat your ass
and then they're keep coming and they're
coming they're Relentless and keep
coming but you know what the highest
level of bully is huh
you bullied they bully you okay you say
something to him they smile at you they
leave
and you don't hear anything about them
ever again
but until one day no you don't hear from
them
slowly but surely your life starts
getting worse and worse and worse in the
most random weird ways those types of
bullies generally work for the
government those types of bullies don't
work like where's Pandora okay those
types of bullies are the kind of bullies
that will use laws will use regulation
we'll use cops we'll use SWAT judges
judges will use everybody to make your
life a living hell until they break you
and all they look forward to is seeing
your broken face one day and you know
what is the look of a broken face of a
man we've seen it many many times
there's many broken faces to see in the
history of mankind there's been many of
them where at one point you're like man
I would have never seen this guy be the
way he is they broke him they break his
family they break his money they break
his morals they break his relationships
they destroy this person so this guy in
in in
Tate he chose out of all the bullies in
the world to say screw this I want to go
up against those bullets yeah when you
go up against those bullies you have to
make sure your army is also filled with
bullies now the kind of bullies that
Tate probably has around him at the
level that he's currently in or what
kind of bullies
he has guys that if you get into a
street fight like there's a video
somebody was sitting on their Bugatti I
don't know if you've seen this video or
not somebody was sitting on the Bugatti
okay it's actually very funny videos I
mean it's not a funny video it's just
entertaining okay these two guys are
sitting on their Bugatti and then next
thing you know Tristan walks up to the
guys like what are you doing get off
punches one the guys knocks him out that
video is out there security cameras
somewhere that I don't know which one it
is Tristan Tate knocks on man for yeah
he's sitting on his Bugatti look at
Tristan watch us oh one more punch is
coming oh and hit the other guy no no no
one more is coming one more is coming
look at this okay and boom Oh [__] so so
now they get back in the Bugatti and
they leave yeah okay you don't sit on
the Bugattis what are you saying okay
cool now but here's the thing Fair Point
you're sitting on some dude I totally
get that but that level of bullying main
matter in the streets that level of
bullying don't matter when you got the
government out those are the ultimate
bullies yeah they're experts can you is
there any way
that you can win against those types no
yes there is yes yes there is the the
way you win you have to make sure you
have a lot of people from a large
establishment organizations that support
you such as
any reason why Dana White's untouchable
are you kidding me Dana White talks at
RNC they know why it puts Trump on his
plane they know why it goes on the you
know Air Force One with Trump they know
why it calls everybody's [__] out
they know why it goes does what he does
they know why he's doing whatever he
wants to do how come nobody goes after
him any reason why they're not targeting
him how come the government how come no
hey how come no one's touching that guy
go ahead and touch him because how many
people support him you know how many
people support him the best football
players yeah the best baseball players
the best actors the best he's won the
Loyalty of so many influencers that they
got us back so what you do with the Dana
White and by the way the thing with Dana
White you gotta also give him respect to
is Dana White has also learn how to be
wise his answers he'll say things like
this look I don't know how you know
Trump here's how I know him when I
needed to get a place to run out to do
my first fight it was he was the first
guy that was there for me he's always
been respectful for me he's always done
this he doesn't go to the levels that he
goes to he just goes right yeah right
yeah so and and the other person that
earned a little bit of Saint status as
well where they almost got him but uh
he's earned Saint status as Joe Rogan
Joe Rogan earned same status when they
try to kind of drop him the the good
decision Joe made Believe It or Not the
best decision Joe made as crazy as this
is going to sound one of the best
decisions Joe made is that he signed his
contract with a company that's not in
the U.S Spotify is not in the U.S Sweden
he's in Sweden like Spotify Sweden's
like dude we deal with the rules and
regulation of Sweden we don't deal we're
not buddies going out to dinner with
these Facebook Google you know all these
people that are on YouTube no we're not
we're on in our own planet in the world
of bodybuilding there was one guy
bodybuilders hated because it was Dorian
Yates and he won six of them the reason
why they hated Dorian Yates is because
he always trained in UK never came to
the parties never went to the club now
he did a little bit but he was a guy
that you wouldn't see him for one year
and he would only do one competition per
year Mr Olympia everybody else is doing
shows shows shows so you would always
see what they're looking like this guy
doesn't do nothing and then all of a
sudden shows up to Mr Olympia takes his
shirt off people like oh holy [__]
so meaning Sweden spotify's sitting
there saying you guys keep talking [__]
to each other we're kind of gonna be
over here okay and we're gonna keep
Rogan we don't care what you say he's
got his own opinions we're going to keep
him on we're not going to cancel him so
I don't know Tata uh he's not naive he
knows what he's doing he knows who he's
targeting there's a reason why he wants
to be in a place like Romania
strategically tater's smarter than this
he knows if it came down to it look I'll
show you something which is so so funny
on how much the media manipulates and
people fall for this [__] right take
a look at this this is one of the
craziest things I saw the other day I'm
going to send it to you Rob and just put
it on the computer so we can see it I
want you I want by the way meanwhile can
you do a poll as well just to see if
people feel there is a credibility there
is you know anything else to it or not
uh uh wait did a poll do you think
Andrew Tate is guilty of human
trafficking uh had
6893 votes 87 said no 87 percent no he
is not guilty of human trafficking 13
said yes yes 87 said no okay interesting
poll well that's our audience I just
sent you I just sent you what I sent you
can you pull up what I just sent you
right there you guys know what I think
would be a great thing Pat and I'm
pretty sure this would be a great bit I
don't know because when you said um UFC
and you know uh Dana White isn't Tate
supposed to fight uh Jake Paul right how
great would that be if he he does get
arrested he's in jail they do the fight
in the middle of like the prison and
it's like Tate versus him and he's in a
Romanian prison I'd pay to watch that I
wouldn't illegally stream it yeah I'd
like to see actually what Logan Paul
says at this point oh we all know would
it be sick day not say anything right
now because coffee zillow's going after
him hardcore oh big time because of
crypto when what happened with crypto so
yeah he's biting
I want you to read this I want you to
read this real quick with me so zoom in
a little bit so everybody can see just
kind of a press the green button yeah
there you go and then okay so check this
out
before Ukraine crisis here's what the
guardian said welcome to Ukraine the
most corrupt nation in Europe after
Ukraine crisis to the right the fight
for Ukraine is a fight for Liberal ideas
I love how you was before Ukraine crisis
Reuters Ukraine's Neo-Nazi problem after
Ukraine crisis Reuters or foreign
Fighters Ukraine offers purpose
camaraderie and a cause Before You Train
Crisis Vox a Ukrainian comedian turned
president in a embroiled is embroiled in
Trump's impeachment mess CNN to the
right ukrainians are giving two lessons
in democracy that Americans have
forgotten about new Europe to the left
before Ukraine crisis Ukrainian
president rule because increasingly
corrupt authoritarian Washington Post
after Ukrainian crisis zelinski the TV
president turned war hero I mean you
know you know what is crazy about this
like here's the part that the part that
that uh you know drives me insane
sometimes is how people are naive and
they're not paranoid and skeptical
enough I trust a guy more that says look
I don't know if Trump did anything with
Russia but maybe he did maybe he did
okay I'm good with that you're right
maybe he did if he did let's see what
the courts have to say even if a person
says right now look man I don't I don't
like this guy I don't like what he says
but maybe he did some of this stuff but
I don't want to jump to conclusion
saying he did I kind of want to learn
more about it let's see what happens
over the next weeks where some other
stories come up how do you believe a
media that at one point was telling you
how horrible
corrupt corrupt Ukraine was just a
couple years ago literally this is not
20 years ago just a couple years ago and
out there telling us the new Churchill
uh leader worldwide is a guy named
zielinski FYI no one's sitting here
telling you Putin is the greatest things
in sliced bread no one's telling you
that all we're saying right now is stop
being so damn naive and believe in
everybody everything you hear so this is
the point I was going to make to Tate
the point I was going to make potatoes
to follow he has to be smart enough
he's a very witty guy but I know the one
benefit he's got it's you know it's the
ultimate benefit a man can have is to
have the brother that he has those two
have a 100 bond with each other which is
like a father's dream okay a father's
dream would be to have your sons be that
tight to each other and they're both
smart and they've been both raised by a
sharp guy which is the father okay
so it's not like this is not a this is a
regular lightweight guy this guy's just
assume all when I hear these guys
talking all I think about here's all I
think about my visual goes to Dad's in
the car driving Andrew sitting shotgun
Tristan sitting in the back and he's
asking what do you think about the CIA
what do you think what just happened
with Russia what do you think about
Stalin what do you think about Leonard
let me tell you history about what
happened in South Africa such and such
years ago let me tell you what's going
on with us let me tell you about Jimmy
Carter let me tell you about this
imagine their car drives you can't talk
like this and think like this without
somebody shaping your mindset and the
only person who can think about is who
the Father the father is who shaped
their mindset to be thinking the way
they're thinking so Tate
if he's the wise
shrewd Street guy that he is
Tate you can't be naive
and believe Romania is going to protect
you because it's a very corrupt Nation
you don't have more money than other
governments that they can offer to that
country
your 50 million hundred million half a
billion a billion is nothing the U.S
just cut a 1.7 trillion dollar check
that's 1700 billion dollars okay the U.S
just gave 2.6 billion dollars for
January 6th attorneys which they just
dropped the case
couple days ago you think they're gonna
have a hard time buying up Ukrainian a
Romanian government to come after you
and don't know there's no way they're
gonna have a hard time with that there's
better places for him to be if they want
to we saw what they did with uh was it
Julian Assange who was it that was a
Snowden or Assange where they said hey
woman this and woman that and Assange
yeah they have way more methods to their
powers than he believes what Tate needs
to do the next phase when he comes back
if he's going to be wise about this the
next time he comes back is build
stronger alliances he doesn't have a lot
of strong alliances he needs strong
alliances okay you need alliances and
alliances are uh he has a lot of people
that believe in him he has a lot of
people that support him he has a lot of
people that like what he has to say but
you need powerful people to have your
back okay you need you need powerful
alliances I I think you know I think
he's got got to be uh the next time
around if he does come back he needs to
have a better strategy of creating
better alliances and aligns the
definition is a union or Association
form for Mutual benefit especially
between countries and or organizations
if I give you if I give you powerful
names and I told you what a license they
have I guarantee you could come up with
a bunch of names for different people I
can give you names right now and you can
say yeah that guy's got this backing
from this guy okay Oprah Winfrey what
alliances does she have go ahead Clinton
yeah okay who else our government
Networks tech obahamas she's connected
Studios
you know how many different insurance
policies that is that's a lot of
different insurance policies yeah okay
what's the knock on Trump how many
alliances does he have even if he has
him he burns him anyway so the challenge
is the alliances he wouldn't keep for
too long right you know Colony long
muscular [__] artist yeah that's an
alliance you could have kept yeah Rogan
is a good alliance to keep like these
are good alliances to keep not everybody
is an enemy
so the challenge with the challenge with
the methodology of bullying all the
bullies is sometimes you bully people
that could have been an alliance to you
that you lose yeah and and that's the
only thing that I think you know part of
it obviously the Playbook of the last
six years is to duplicate what Trump did
but
duplicating that without building
alliances long term
it's uh it's it's not it's not the right
strategy I don't think I could be wrong
I don't think that's the right strategy
number one I think what you said was
beyond powerful so like yeah clip that
up clip it boom but
the way that I'm interpreting these
alliances is so there's there's top down
and bottom up okay so one of the more
powerful things that I remember what
Tate said when he talked about Logan
Paul was he's like Logan Paul has
followers
I have fans and there's a big difference
like they're wondering where's Tate
let's go find Tate whereas he compared
uh Logan Paul to sort of a tool of the
Matrix and a monkey and people watch but
they don't they're not fans got you so
all right where am I going with this
we're speaking of alliances so top down
bottom up
bottom up would be the Groundswell of
people that genuinely want to see this
guy win fans okay there's no doubt he
has millions and millions of fans hey
you doubt that oh for sure no doubt okay
so that's the bottom-up approach like
I'm not comparing Tate to Gandhi but if
you start on the Grassroots or if it's a
a Bernie Sanders whether it's a trump
you have a Groundswell of people you
have a ground game from the bottom up
that will support you you need that
right
the problem is what Tate doesn't have is
that he doesn't have a top-down approach
there's nobody in the upper echelons of
government Tech Society the global Elite
that is going to come to his defense
nobody and I think that's what you're
referring to when it comes to alliances
you can have the bottom-up approach
amazing but if you're going to go
against the system you better have some
big Bazookas up at the top they're going
to have your back oh but by the way I
think he's got the personality to get
that uh FY some people are dming me
stuff and and from different parts of
the world uh Rob can you do me a favor
and put my link to my Twitter profile if
anybody has anything that they want to
share and some of the credible stuff if
you can't send it to me I'll I'll bring
it up if you don't want your name to be
mentioned because of whoever you are
I'll respect that no problem but if you
do want uh uh feel free to send this
stuff to my uh Twitter profile just put
the link below the easiest way for
people to go to it so no question but
here's the thing here's the thing that
he has going for himself
he's likable
okay he's very likable he's Charming
he's likable uh uh uh put the exact link
uh exact link to put okay there you go
he's Charming he's likable he's witty
he's smart he's funny
he's also polarizing he's very
polarizing I get that but what I'm
saying is he has the ability to win
Saint status and earn a lot of people's
support he has that oh he has to uh he
has to change uh he has to change his
approach here's the other thing that you
got to be thinking about as well
said something with somebody who was on
I don't know somebody sent me this clip
where he says look the difference
between men and women is the following
if you have a past as a woman and you're
38 single you're trying to get like this
girl yesterday
I don't even know who this comedian was
yesterday she deleted all the tweets a
guy sent me the tweets he's like listen
you know she she saved it because here's
what she said let me see if I even have
this picture the guy sent me about what
this lady tweeted so the first tweet
from hers was something like
um
I have to show you guys because it's too
funny this morning I woke up everybody's
dming me saying hey guess what she
deleted everything she said about you
etc etc but we saved it we have it don't
worry about it okay yes uh here so so
here's a okay let me just send you uh uh
uh [__] I have to yeah I got all of them
oh fantastic oh yeah okay they send it
all right so let me send this to you
this is a girl named Nicole Arbor I
don't know who she is me neither man and
by the way she may be a very likable
person she may be somebody that's liked
by a lot of people that uh we like I
don't even know this I don't know who
this person is but she responded to my
tweet Rob if you got it just kind of
pull it up and upload that first and
then we'll read this tweet I don't want
you to go to this tweet yet I want you
to first read the tweets I sent you yeah
so okay go go pull up the tweet I sent
you and and then I'll tell you where I'm
going with this if you can pull this up
okay go in so my tweet that I read
earlier you know the one that I said
don't know exactly what happened with
okay but they have the greater number
because here here's a response go down
she says uh uh not that strange Patrick
one is an American issue and one is a
multiple rape allegation human
trafficking and allegation that have
been going on since April and a bucket
of other possible charges in Romania ask
your friend Ina's Freedom Cantor what he
thinks about human trafficking again I
know nothing about what she's saying
here okay all of it could be true okay
so my response to her is the following
okay if you want to go show the second
one I don't know the second one I sent
you that I send you two pictures get
away from this one here a Rob and go to
the other one I sent you I send you two
pictures if you can pull up the other
one okay do you have it or no yeah okay
so the second one is
um
and you don't know this girl
period at all and imagine my community
never met her I have no idea I don't
know who she is okay because I don't
either so then this is my response to
her so if you go to the bottom I said
you sound emotional yet certain
I'm choosing to be logical yet paranoid
but you also sound like somebody who may
have been attracted to him but he had
zero interest in you if that's the case
I'm sorry he hurt your feelings
meanwhile I'm waiting patiently to learn
more a troll level 100 by the way
straight up wait you're giving opinion
yeah and you're kind of trolling
responding to me and she calls me you
sound like a typical beta male okay and
and she deletes that after she calls me
a typical beta male then I said the
following I said LOL I just realized
you're a comedian I can appreciate your
sense of humor but if I'm a beta male
wouldn't that make you an alpha female
no 40 years old single not married no
kids mic drop maybe there's a reason for
that sweet dreams my job and then and
then you see her tweet at the top
she deleted it so but the point is the
following the point is the following
none of us know what's fully going on
everybody here could be wrong like if if
God forbids something happens all of a
sudden to this guy he goes to jail for
15 years you have to know people are
going to come after us and they're going
to be like oh my God you know you were
you gave this kind of platform you did
this and you're part of the problem as
well all this stuff they're gonna say
yeah and then if the opposite happens
and he's out he's innocent you have to
also realize people are like I told you
you jump to conclusion the whole part of
this thing here is sometimes like I'll
never forget when I hit rock bottom oh
bro the BET do you know
it was the sickest thing when I had Rock
Bottom okay
the guy that I was always on the fence
to see if he was really a best friend or
if he was a hater okay you know how long
it took me to figure that out one second
shut up no well one time what was the
moment
and then uh so what happened was Ward
came back to me text messages all this
other stuff saying let me tell you what
this guy said about you I said got it
well I'm not surprised finally validated
that uh I was right that guy was a waste
of time okay I gave him credit you know
benefited a doubt but he was right
you know what happened the guys I
thought didn't have my back had my back
many of the guys I thought had my back
didn't have my back the greatest
filtering system in life is when you
have a massive crisis in your life
you can immediately filter out 90 of
people in your life what types of Crisis
bankruptcy divorce loss of a loved one
drug use setbacks you're messed up
falling out it's the fastest way to
filter out the real people and the fake
people in your life immediately there's
nothing like it the cousin you thought
was the best cousin that he's been
jealous for a long time he's just never
revealed it until your fall the best
friend you had that you know you thought
he was like the guy that had your back
and it was right next to you and like oh
this is my guy no it wasn't he's been
waiting for you to have a fall because
he's internally envious of all the
attention and all this all that you're
getting he's sick of it do you know what
happened with one of the guys that was
the guy that turned his back uh on me
what right before we leave Texas he
invites me to go to rafi's place and I
go to rafi's place with them and we sit
down
and I said to him I said hey so what's
going on he says yeah I want to pay for
lunch I said you know you've never paid
for lunch I always pay for lunch what
are you doing like what's this act all
about I said look man I'm gonna pay for
my lunch today I'm not paying for your
lunch you can cover your lunch but I'm
gonna pay for my lunch today
but I want to tell you everything
okay
and I just went through all of it and by
the time it was done I said dude it's
been awesome I wish you nothing but the
best I hope all your dreams become a
reality but moving forward we're
acquaintances there's no more friendship
here okay uh God knows I want every
single one of your dreams to still come
become a reality because I know where
I'm going with my life I don't there's
plenty of success for all of us to get
it all you can get it if you're more
successful than me more power to you but
I'm looking for real relationship in my
life and you're just not one of them
okay good luck with you the look on his
face changed so many different times
okay because in life you can make
millions
you can have all the women in the world
you can have the cars you can have the
houses
you can have the clothes you can have
the accolades you can have all of that
nothing is more valuable than real
relationships where you can just sit
there do nothing chill out and you know
that person's not going to judge you
Jordan said something about his
relationship with Tiger Woods
he says you know when tiger comes to our
place
I want him to feel safe I want him to
feel like he can be whoever he wants to
be because no one's going to know we're
not going to judge him he says because
that's how I feel with tiger it's very
hard to have people like that in your
life when you make it to the levels that
tiger and some of us have made it right
there's only a few Andrews in the world
right now okay he just filtered out 99
of the people in his life okay and the
one percent that is there those
relationship he best value because
they're very very hard to find
especially as you age but the the
greatest filtering process we just saw
right there within a 24-hour period is
all the people that came out and said
what they said now you know the other
thing that the point I was going to make
here's is the following as well we all
have a past
you have a past Adam's got a past we all
got to pass okay and he's got to pass
this well we don't know everything about
the past all we know about him is six to
12 months remember that one clip that
came out he hit a girl and I can't
believe you're supporting this because
you're like I've never seen this before
let me see this oh the girl said they
were doing some kinky stuff turns out
she was into it yeah yeah and she made a
video and say no this is kind of what
things we did private okay fine great
you know a lot of things like this came
out oh he paid her off he did okay
whatever I I'm not sitting here telling
you this guy's an angel okay believe me
there's a lot of words we've used to get
a girl to be willing to have sex with
you I mean if you know the book uh uh
Think and Grow Rich Napoleon Hill said
something very powerful uh sex
transmutation I don't know if you've
heard the phrase sex transmutation yeah
of course type in the word chapter 10.
Jesus shut up I swear to God chapter 10
I'm gonna be very important yeah it is
by the way this is one of the reasons
why I went 17 months without sex yeah
this guy and another guy this guy the
two guys I won 17 months without it was
a hard I ever did my temper was a horse
I was lifting weights like you wouldn't
believe I'd go to the gym I'm like put
another plate
because I want another appetizer hurry
up anyways so he talks about sex
transmutation and one of the things he
talks about in this chapter is the fact
that men will say anything
in the moment like right before you're
about to be done or right before you're
about to close men will say anything to
get a woman to go in bed with them you
know but babe listen how do you expect
me to show you love if if you're not
letting me like that's how I'm able to
only show love to you you know last
night I was having a dream in the middle
of the night I woke up I looked to my
right I thought you were next to me you
weren't I cried all I thought about was
you we will say the dumbest oh thing
about moving your family bring your
money bring your mind I'm allergic by
the way if you're a guy and you're
sitting here saying I've never said
anything like that you are full of [__]
is what you are I've always loved you
the moment I saw you but by the way I'm
not I'm not uh Sensational I'm just
saying it's a weakness of men that we
are willing to say some stupid [__]
together yes so am I am I sitting here
saying Tate hasn't used some lines like
that and by the way as good as you think
you are with lines I guarantee you he's
better than those moments so okay all
I'm saying is the following
he has to as quickly as possible change
his brand disconnect with old whatever
happened get that stuff situated lawyers
where you made money whatever you did
make it good with everybody you ever
screwed whatever you did
he has to make those things good because
a big part one of the stories was like
in UK XYZ happened the reason why he
left UK because one of the girls that he
said you never paid me so you know
you're gonna I'm gonna do this and so he
left UK to go to uh Romania anyways
these are stories I don't know the full
credit bill credibility behind it these
are holy stories that he went to Romania
if he's gonna come back which this guy's
got he's he's like a cat he's got
multiple lives this guy's gonna come
back yeah and he's on his seventh life
or sixth life you have to change some of
your strategies and you have to figure
out a way to clean up anything from your
past by getting the right lawyers making
all the old enemies into friends and
allies and moving forward so you think
there is a so two things I want to say
so you think there is a chance for him
to redeem and I mean how do you
basically tell the government United
States government listen yeah I know I
poked at you a couple times I'm sorry
number one number two Pat you're talking
about not the government I didn't say
the government but you know what I'm
talking about he's pissed off a lot of
no no but he can't go back in Apollo you
don't apologize to the government no no
no that's what I'm saying so you think
you think it's too late for him to do
that cleanup thing that you're talking
about no it's kind of like this if
you're running for office the first
thing you got to do is call every single
one of your exes and meet with them wow
you just have to do that I don't think
what I said is anything unique you have
to meet with every one of them say so
listen I just want to talk to you how
are you doing good
anything you're upset with me okay
anything that frustrated you tell me
where you're at okay I want to tell you
19 years ago XYZ I want to apologize
that was not cool what I did I'm truly
sorry I effed up okay you have to have
those conversations if you're running
for office you have to call family
friends enemies allies access and have
those conversations and in that moment
you're gonna know this is not gonna be
fixed and this is going to come back up
guess what I can't run for office okay
he has to treat this because what he's
doing is a form of running for office
the office he's running for is the
president of the internet he's not
running for the office of President of
you know United he's running to be the
president of the internet if you're
running to be the president of the
internet you have to kind of go back and
look at some of those relationship and
making good and 100 you got them because
you don't walk on water none of us do
this isn't a pass at him this is just if
you're really wanting that kind of
respect and accolades you got to make
some of those calls and those are
private apologies they're not publicly
it's more important it's one-on-one face
to face it case it takes courage to do
those it's very tough to do yes what I
will say by the way great observation
president so I I I I actually had a
conversation about this with my good
buddy Michael Sartain is basically
saying today in today's society the
eyeball attention economy where
everything's about clicks and Views and
and eyeballs and and subscribers and all
that we're in a we're in a different
time where it used to be good versus bad
USA versus the USSR right Hulk Hogan
versus The Iron cheek like there was a
clear distinction between who was the
good guy who was the bad guy these days
the lines are completely blurred it's
just who has the most followers who has
the most Cloud who gets the most
eyeballs and if you're running for the
president the internet you're Andrew
Tate
you know how they say like other than
like literally going to jail like I
don't care what you say about me just
spell my name right yeah everybody knows
how to spell t-a-t at this point okay so
he's
fully qualified to be president of the
internet good bad or indifferent okay
whether you're Kanye whether you're
Trump whether you're freaking Billy
McFarland from the from the uh whether
you're uh Sam bakeman freed fire
Festival guys they might have a good
freed FTX people want to know your story
the bigger that you get if birdie Madoff
were alive he'd be on a [__] podcast
right now I'm like Bernie let's hear the
deal what you had going on yeah so fully
fully endorse what you're saying right
now well I actually just want to make an
apology it was chapter 11. okay of uh
think and growing don't make that
mistake follow my Napoleon Hill fans out
there I think a girl which like Adam
you're an idiot you're scumbag is
chapter 11. I apologize right there but
what you said is so true about sex tram
mutation and it's been years since I
read this book but essentially tell me
if I'm wrong the premise was some of the
greatest men in history were absolute
like sex beasts Abraham Lincoln George
Washington Einstein Thomas Jefferson
these guys were lover boys to use that
term to a little callback right there
but they took that energy and that
passion and that like that you have as a
man and funneled it into something
positive or creative or scientific or
leadership or political aspirations or
whatever and you hope you harness that
power for greatness essentially I think
that's what you did for that 17-month
celibacy I'm working on 17 days but it's
such a powerful comment but what you
also said was actually very true about
what guys will say to women it's because
women men fall in love with their eyes
women fall in love with their ears what
does that mean men are visual creatures
right eighty percent of the reason that
a guy dates a girl is how she looks of
course and there's 20 that's like what's
her values what's her principles what's
her age like all that but it's very very
much a looks conditional thing okay for
women falling in love with their ears
it's it's not all about looks it's about
what you do for work what's your status
what car do you drive are you a good
person do you like kittens do you help
old ladies across the street are you
funny you're creative are you a man are
you an alpha and the the the the pie
graph is actually
dispersed across the place so what does
that mean a man falls in love with his
eyes because he likes how beautiful a
woman is a man knows that he has to say
some [__] 100 to impress a woman and you
were going here you were going here with
a different direction where a man uh
you're you're I think you were going
here with the past and the future men
care about a woman's past women care
more about a man's future
so if you find out that this girl you're
dating used to be a stripper or a hoe or
a cardi B type girl I don't care where
she's at today it's like I can't bring
this girl out in public if a woman finds
out that that dude used to be like
homeless like uh to had sex with a ton
of women and just was like an [__]
whatever but now he's cleaned it up and
his future looks bright women will jump
all over that versus a man will not go
back and and try to relive a woman's
checkered past I want to read this tweet
to you that just came in right now for
Mario nafal Just In in less than an hour
the Tate brothers will arrive before the
judges at Bucharest Court to find out
whether or not they will spend the
holidays Behind Bars whether or not the
30-day preventative arrest warrant
requested by the prosecutors will be
confirmed uh this just came in an hour
ago so literally how long ago yeah about
an hour ago ate 14. so meaning they're
in court right now
and we're gonna see what's gonna be
happening I think a lot of different
stories are going to come out today
go go uh
yeah I think a lot of different stories
are going to come out today and uh
nobody fully has an idea what's gonna
ask you a question so uh and just just
to go back a little bit not to go too
far but remember you saying like you
find out who your real friends are the
real fam whoever family when you hit
that rock body my question was going to
be what if you don't have one of those
moments where like you do fall and you
don't get to see a pet and your life is
just kind of going good How do you How
would how do you really find out who'll
be success success is the other way it's
either hardcore failure or hardcore
success because when you when you
succeed you know the the butt butt like
you know yeah I mean Vinnie's doing this
but let's not forget you know you know
yeah yeah you know they got but you know
you're trying to find the butt community
the butt community and I'm not talking
about Community you've been looking for
your entire life I'm talking about a
different Community one tea not two T's
right I mean success and where you are
hey look if you see Vinnie is what
vitamins doing this is done yeah but
listen let me tell you that's because
what happened during covid yeah really
heard his career about they're gonna
make you know so and all of those
stories are gonna come out all of those
stories are gonna come out yeah I mean
the the the the best the best way to
identify who's got your back and who
does not is when you fall uh you know
like when you fall so much I told you
never do that I told you got it I got
you um yeah I got you okay cool so
listen uh look at this point I don't
need to tell you already know you
shouldn't have done that but look what
are we doing from here here's what I
suggest we doing okay hey you know I got
a girl pregnant last night I met you
know she know I got a girl pregnant a
month and a half ago that I met at the
club she wants to keep the baby baby I
don't know what the hell to do
I mean you know you screwed up I do okay
dude what do we do is she keeping her
she's choosing to keep it okay you got
to work with that what are we doing now
we got to go make some money we gotta
figure this so you will know by the way
people answer by the way one of the best
things Jordan Peterson said I had him at
an event and he was talking about his
next book coming up
Jordan Peterson talked about if you
really want to know if people have your
back or not
say some good and say some bad about
yourself and just watch the reaction
if you say something bad about yourself
that happened and you look at them and
that you can tell there's a part of
celebration going on oh wow you can tell
where they're at but if you say good
things about yourself and you see how
what they turn into you can also kind of
tell where they're at but you will know
more about them if you say bad things
then you will know versus when you say
good things uh I have look I'm I'm a I'm
an extremely logical and paranoid guy
skeptical guy and I'm not looking to
have a billion great relationships I I
I'm looking to have a handful to ten
phenomenal valuable relationships in
life outside of my family meaning
there's there's no relationship more
important you want to have them with
your kids your wife your family all that
that's very important but outside of
that friends non-blood five to ten if
you got five like tens in your life dude
you have the same amount of wealth as
Elon Musk has if you have five tens
like ride or die type of buddies in your
life great you're the richest man in the
world I like that you're the richest man
in the world now if you can make some
money as well you can enjoy the money
with your friends yeah yeah because yeah
it sucks when you don't have the money
to enjoy those special moments together
you know so uh uh uh again we're gonna
see what's gonna happen here with this
guy I'll add to that like if my mom
watches this clip she's gonna like fail
right it's out of Tears my mom the
number one lesson she would tell me as a
kid is like
in order to have a friend you need to be
a friend and like I say this all the
time I don't have any hobbies in my life
I don't go rock climbing I don't do I
don't collect baseball cards I got
nothing going on about all the stamp
collection
I value friendship I like hanging out
with my boys I like making money I like
hanging out pretty girls I'm a very
simple dude but to Pat's to basically
what Pat's saying is there's a couple
quotes we can talk about right here but
essentially like value those who
um will support you when they have
nothing to gain that like essentially
like
um
who will have you in your life when you
have nothing to offer other than
yourself just being there for you
there's a famous quote by Oprah what's
I'm gonna read the quote she says um
um
lots of people want to ride with you in
the limo
but what you want is someone who will
take the bus with you when the limo
breaks down so when you have nothing to
offer other than your company that is a
true sign of a friendship like the guy
the the guy that you went to lunch with
at rafi's place I don't know the
relationship but was he using you for
something or what was the what was the
situation it was a competitive
environment yeah it was like Hey because
what frustrated him the most is the fact
that I won without getting a college
degree and all of them went and got the
college degrees and to them to their
families every time I would go around
their families it was like when are you
going to get your degree when are you
going to get your degree such and such
got his degree such and such got his
degree when are you going to get your
degree when are you going to get your it
was always that conversation I'm like
yeah guys I'm not going to get my degree
and then when I blew up after telling
them what I was gonna do that was when
it was the end of it they were not happy
uh about the level of success that came
afterwards but some of the guys one guy
was freaking straight up he says look
took me to Conrad's shout out to Adrian
this guy took me to Conrad's and said
look Pat I got to just be honest with
you I thought you were going to be the
biggest failure out of all of our
friends really I thought you were going
to be the biggest failure I thought you
were going to do nothing with your life
and the fact that you have has shocked
the hell out of me but I just want to
tell you I'm proud of you man that's
awesome guess what I was like dude
respect good for you I I you know what I
appreciate it he's got a great life
today he's successful he's doing good
for himself but you know I I learned
some of them were more up to games
behind closed doors versus the other way
around hey Pat has money you pay for it
hey let's go to Pat's place for the
party but hey we're doing a gathering at
the house let's remind everybody about
Pat you know because I might make you
uncomfortable and all the people that
have all the fancy degrees get together
and I'm not there I'm totally fine with
that I'm very comfortable in my own skin
all I'm saying is
you're going to know as you succeed
if some of the guys that were you know
maybe ahead of you at the time and now
you're ahead of them that messes what a
lot of people says got you and I like
the fact that you said that because I I
honestly was like I'm trying to figure
out if your life is just chilling and
you're going like this because I haven't
fallen Fallen I've had I've had bad
stuff happen in my life and I've had
friends there I'll go back to when you
were the Airman of the year what are you
talking about yeah there's a lot of guys
that were not happy that we've been here
haters but I mean that's what you're
saying is the opposite is is nothing
happening here you were nothing when
your children where are those snakes
believe me a lot of the people that were
ahead of you in comedy who have never
had a video get a couple hundred million
views are sitting there saying freaking
guys I'm seeing them everywhere right
now you secretly some of them are not
celebrating you don't see it yeah I got
you yeah but just be patient just be
patient you're gonna you're gonna learn
a lot but put the put that picture
well I want to get your actually your
perspective on this as a father with two
boys and two girls yep and this goes
back to what we're talking about with
Tate and sort of the uh how he calls out
sort of the new wave New Age modern
women boss babe feminists so
you know you would hear
you know peripherally I don't know how
much you paid attention to it that the
future is female
have you heard this before the future's
female I don't know if you know that the
future is female and okay like that
stuff you would just hear peripherally
have you ever heard that before this is
the first time I've ever heard you've
never heard the future women are killing
it I'm proud of them I never heard of it
but have you heard this the future is
female Rob have you heard this yes the
future is female I don't know so like
I'm like
all right that's I didn't really look
into that although all right cool good
luck ladies like I I have a mom I have a
grandma and my sister I have a girl like
nieces love you guys awesome the
future's female and I'm like what do you
mean the future's female
so like is it I mean like what role is
men gonna have if the future is female
Are We Now second-class citizens are we
now not expected to be what we
potentially could be and I started
delving into this topic of modern
feminism and and just kind of going down
that rabbit hole about how like how
women say like
I Don't Need No Man like there's a song
like sweetie like I'm a bad [__] make
my own money don't need no man it's like
what do you mean you don't need a man or
if you're a lesbian I get it yeah
whatever but if you're just a chick that
says she don't need a man you have no
idea
how many women I know in their late 30s
in their early 40s message to the
females out there who I say hey how you
doing like because I'm in my early 40s
you are as well I said what's up like
you're a beautiful girl in high school
I've known you for years I said you got
a man
no you you got kid no you you want kids
yeah so how old are you 42 41 38 39 44.
I said you you get you freezing your
eggs
I swear yeah I'm asking women these
questions like you're being genuine they
go yeah I'm freezing my eggs wow I'm I'm
like and this is happening more and more
companies are even actually paying for
women to freeze their eggs because they
want you to work they want you to work
be a boss babe you don't need no man get
your money girl whatever get that bag
and then it's like well let's find out
what's actually happening to these women
turns out these conversations they're
like yeah really really [__] this one up
I really wish that I didn't abide by the
whole I don't need no man I'm not gonna
settle for no man because what's
happening right now is all these boss
babes these feminists they and get
indoctrinated into this the future is
female you don't know man you can do it
which is great to at a certain extent
but when you hit quote unquote the wall
it has a woman and next thing you know
you're 40 and you don't have no man and
you've got three cats and a couple
dildos hanging around I'm just saying
it's like all of a sudden you're like I
probably shouldn't have hated on men all
that and a couple legs in the freezer
yeah and the eggs in the freezer but so
part of what Tate says this is why he
pisses women off is that he says he'll
says things that will what's the word
that's the word of the year when you
trigger somebody or do you roll no no
gas light when you Gaslight something
exactly he'll say like and he said this
in the interview rather than saying men
are stronger than women which I think we
can agree men are stronger woman's not
controversial who say things like women
are weak yeah or rather than saying that
like you know men are better drivers
than women he'll say women can't drive
so that'll trigger a lot of women and I
think essentially what his message is
though and what my message I think
anyone's messages is that men and women
are equal but they're also different
this is called Duality or polarity in
life is that there's two sides of a coin
right there's ying and the Yang there's
the Sun and the Moon there's the you
know there's black and white whatever
you want to look at it and they're both
equal
but they're different and the problem
that I think that he's saying the while
he's triggering so many women is he's
basically
he's kind of like they think that he's
like dunking on women and that's not
necessarily the case he's saying there's
things that you're qualified for better
than a man and there's things that men
are qualified better for a woman for
example like you'll have to see these
conversations with feminists there's
like what do I need a man for what do I
need a man for it's like well the office
that you're sitting in the whole [__]
building was built by a man the roads
were built by a man by the way when the
bad guys come and attack you the women
aren't running the women go get you know
if there's a ship that's sinking the
women and kids go on the uh on the on
the safety raft the men go to war so
it's like all this [__] on men is
becoming like to the point where this is
what produces a tate the same reason
that Obama will produce a trump the same
reason that modern day feminism will
produce a tate anyway my question for
you is you need a woman that's what
you're trying to say of course what
you're saying is a famous philosopher
said you years ago yeah this is a man's
world nothing nothing without without a
woman or a girl yes and I fully endorsed
that so by the way I don't know if
unless there's something that has
fundamentally changed it takes a man and
a woman to create a baby yes I know a
lot of people today guys it's a science
class but here's my question to you I've
been waiting for it yes well here you go
you know you have two boys yes you have
two girls yes
if Santa or if any of like any girl
comes to you and says the future's
female Future's female like what would
you explain to your sons when they say
well I don't know Dad like all these
girls are here in class that the Futures
FEMA what does that mean for me as a boy
as a man who I would say as a leader a
qualified man a man amongst men the type
of man that men want to be like and
women want to be what type of a thing
what do you explain to your sons when
you hear that the future is female and
men are now becoming second-class
citizens I mean that's going to be the
last concern of mine when it comes up
because we're going to talk about all
these issues when they do come up
um yeah you're just going to have a
conversation with them about it there's
value in areas that women lead and
there's going to be areas that you lead
in I'm not going to sit here and say one
uh uh is great at everything and you
know the other sucks no there's certain
roles that we play those conversations
are already being had in our household
and if you raise them right till 18 from
there they're going to make some
decisions some of them you can agree
with some of them you're not going to
agree with do me a favor go back to
Mario in the Fall's tweet he just posted
something I want to show this go back to
you he just said uh click on it and go
back yeah to see whatever he go down go
down go down he just says yeah keep
going down keep going down keep going
down uh keep going down keep going down
keep going down there's um
he they just invited me on their live
today for 2PM keep going a little lower
keep going a little lower it's like two
hours ago you still gotta go keep going
keep going by the way who is this Mario
in the fall he's actually very good
citizen journalist online okay so today
will be more released Romanian
authorities the rest will be likely
prolonged to 30 days a few times Max is
180 days as investigations continues
unlikely to get bail
and they face up to 20 years in jail
that's yesterday nine hours ago is what
they were talking about okay what the
Romanian attorney was talking about you
can't get on bail when you're facing
charges for crimes that have a direct
intention both rape and traffic fall
into this category crimes that could be
punished with more than seven years of
prison both rape and traffic and five to
ten years now here's the part I just got
a couple messages from people in Romania
here's here's what couple said
um
one is uh uh uh uh please do not mention
my name I will not mention your name on
who you are but this person lives in
Romania okay he said uh uh he has been
connected with the Romanian Elite who is
the elite in Romania the Orthodox Church
the politicians the police he made huge
donations to the Orthodox Church however
he recently converted to Islam Romania
is one of the most Christian countries
in the world and he may have pissed off
the wrong people his conversion to Islam
was a slap in the face to many
high-profile religious persons in
Romania this is just my own Insight okay
wow good point yeah good opinion that's
one that was said uh now another one
that just came in right now saying it's
not going to be about rape allegations
and any of this stuff it's going to be
more about money laundering you got to
be careful with money laundering taxes
any of that that's where they get you
but but listen here's the here's the
other part if if the government really
wanted to get you really really wanted
to get you they can figure out ways to
say you didn't 22 dollars you didn't pay
17 years ago in taxes and you know
you're short on this again there's so
many creative ways for them to come
after you if they choose to do so it's
not hard for them to do it uh uh so the
louder you are the more targets you got
and the louder you are your biggest
insurance policies is to make sure some
of the biggest institutions in the world
have your back because behind closed
doors they got to be negotiating
Brittany grinder how long did it take
her to get out six months of a month
almost seven it's a long time guys of
course that's not a you know and what
did U.S have to give up
and The Merchant of death well first of
a horrible negotiation nearly 10 months
by the way 10 months oh wow horrible
negotiation on our end okay I want to
know what we would have given up for
LeBron
[Music]
LeBron's got the most powerful
institutions that have his back he
wouldn't stay for a split because he has
good relationship he has good alliances
you want to stay for a split second
because he's got a line call back
strategy strategy it's all in strategy
in the next move if this thing ends and
he's out he has to change his Strat he
has to take a week off and purely decide
where he's going to be building his
alliances does he stay in Romania
I think you made a great Point here
because I'm just going back uh to the
interview we had the reason that he
lives in Romania is because it has
Traditional Values he was Christian at
the time and he says that it's like the
most Christian
place in Europe and they value you know
judeo-christian values and everything
like that so what you said about the
fact that he did convert to Islam I
don't know about 30 60 days ago
that I can under I can appreciate why
the Orthodox Church of Romania views
that as a slap in the face is that what
the guy basically said in the in the
Tweet yeah because he said that imagine
you said the the Christian they're
they're running the show over there yeah
when he gets out you know where he's
moving Dubai Sweden no I don't know
about Sweden but yeah he's moving to
Dubai I I would as a Muslim a wealthy
guy he's gonna yeah Dubai would probably
be the spot I I'm curious to see what do
what what do what do you guys think will
he do any time like not not this 30 day
whatever I'm talking about will he be
will he be sent to prison in Romania I'm
curious to what people I don't know I
don't even want to speculate on that
because essentially what Pat's saying is
like look he might have done this I hope
it's not true so I'm not wishing
anything bad for the dude
you know good relationship with them but
it's like it's one of those things where
it's like
like what you were saying is like the
government will do it like you can go
back and they found twenty dollars that
you didn't like yeah report on your tax
yeah your W-2s 1099 whatever it is from
14 years ago they'll get you of course
if they want to get you they will get
you even if you are innocent oh yeah
that's the scary thing right now is that
he's poking the Bears so much you gotta
stop dude well I mean but here's the
thing he know like dude the guy has
basically predicted everything that's
gonna happen so that goes back to my
question I was like bro you you you did
what you did you knew the consequences
you already set up he already says that
the three tiers of his of the life the
Matrix um they cancel you they put you
in prison and then they're gonna try to
kill you if you if you get out of prison
do I mean so it's like either he was
doing it to do it to get the eyeballs
and become famous and he's that guy but
number two is like are you ready to get
the real like repercussions of your
actions because yo either he's like a
modern day you know masculine he wants
men to be and he's sticking up for for
that generation or he's just like hey I
was just trying to get eyeballs and now
it's like oh [__] this thing is this
thing has gone real so
I don't know it's gonna be an
interesting next couple days you guys
did you guys find out who uh in the in
the government
held fouchy accountable meaning who
played the role accountable no no no oh
what do you mean did you see who he
reported to that Health out she
accountable the story have you guys seen
this or no okay so go to Twitter go to
uh let me find this for you
which by the way it's kind of weird when
you see the story here I'll send it to
you very very weird story and then we'll
look it up we'll we'll validate it we'll
go to Snopes to see if there's any
credibility
when I show this to you you're gonna say
don't say it so the audience can see it
for themselves okay it's it's a very
very weird person to report to got you
okay and he just he just today was his
last day right patchy's done today today
was the day bye bye is that why you were
a little bit emotional I could not
I couldn't even
that little rat is gone
yeah I didn't I didn't want to I didn't
want to almost saw that I saw what you
were going through no the craziest thing
about uh a musk see musk tweeted this if
you can find this I don't know if you
can find this or not because
uh
books he just went four books and wrote
one no he he posted a tweet saying the
person that fauci reports to that holds
him accountable in the US government is
his wife okay is that the one yeah right
there zoom in on that one right there is
that the one okay the first sentence of
New York can profile the walls in Dr
Anthony fauci's home office are adorned
with portraits of him drawn and painted
oh God by some of his many fans he loves
himself yeah but there's a story he
posted where is this I mean I hope he
didn't take it down uh keep going keep
going keep going there's a story about
who he reports to
oh my god oh you gotta find this
Elon is too active on Twitter man
I mean he owns it he's way well he's
using his product I mean it is what it
is but yeah it's a story that came out
about uh who his direct report is
um and this is like four days ago I'm
trying to go far back to see if we can
find it
okay well why don't you go to fauci's uh
uh Wikipedia go to fauci's Wikipedia
you'll find it
Wikipedia I can't wait okay go to Fox's
Wikipedia
and you see go to his wife
to the right who's married to okay zoom
in a little bit so we can see it
Christy Grady right okay so who is
Christy Grady go to Christine crady
watch this zoom in Christine Grady is an
American and bioethics who serves as the
head of the Department of bioethics at
the National Institute of Health
clinical Center NIH NIH wow that's so
her job is to hold him accountable what
did you did you did you just
okay so the basically the the the HR of
your job is your wife
there's no country there's no conflict
of interest there no way are you are you
kidding me can you like not real that's
that can't be real no no that is that
real that is real but go to you know I'm
on some Refuge discovery about the liar
Anthony fauci okay let's see what this
says here go
zoom in fauci was untruthful to Congress
but Wuhan lab research new documents
approach to snow but but go keep going
keep going keep going keep going keep
going
um
no no keep going the one I want to see
about is his connection with his wife
that's all I care about in this story
I'm going to go back to the connection
with his wife bro if your wife is
overseeing your good and bad there
there's how the hell did they let that
happen see this is the kind of stuff
that the a person that says what's wrong
with that yeah listen you're part of the
problem 100 if you don't have the
ability to question stuff like this
you're also part of the problem right
they're zooming on the bottom right the
bottom bottom bottom bottom bottom no no
bottom right there zoom in almost no one
seems to realize that the head of
bioethics at the NIH the person who was
supposed to make sure that fauci behaves
ethically is his wife what the hell is
his wife this whole time
a function in this context is just
another way of saying bio weapon some
good nuckets in an article important to
note that fauci author 2012 paper
arguing for gain of function research
Obama wisely put this on pause but fauci
restarted it so go back to Wikipedia
let's read a Wikipedia a little bit more
okay so zoom in go go actually to her
Wikipedia this is the ghetto version of
it go to the real version of it this is
just pedia yeah go to go to file go to
yeah right there so let's read the zoom
in zoom in zoom in let's read it
together guys we're gonna have a quick
uh reading here Grady uh was born and
raison
okay go to Career go to Korea Grady has
worked in nursing clinical research and
clinical care with a specialization in
HIV she was a commissioner on the
presidential commission in the for the
study bioethical issues from 2012 to
2017. uh that's Obama until Trump showed
up and she probably got fired Grady is a
member of the uh National maybe she got
a promotion which is great to remember
the National Academy of Medicine a
senior fellow at the Kentucky Institute
of ethics and a fellow of the Hastings
Center and American Academy of nursing
she received the National Institutes of
Health CEO award in 2017 and the
director's award from the same
organization in 2015 and 17 grade he was
married to Anthony fauci in American
immunologist and a head of National
Institute of allergy and infectious
diseases at the National Institute of
Health they have three daughters
together a little weird what do you mean
a little weirdo I I I actually want to
give you some feedback on tell me okay
the more and more I read all this I'm
just going back to your theory on
alliances
there's a entire alphabet soup of
alliances right there the NIH the CIA
the DEH the boy the FDA the FBI is all
connected
fauci whether he is guilty or not guilty
of doing whatever it is based on those
alliances of all the alphabet soup
that's going on there Untouchable
nothing's happening exactly I said that
has happened listen to me Untouchable
and you know what's crazy he yells at
people when he's in Congress by the way
why don't you type in fouchy wife Snopes
okay faucy wife Snopes let's maybe
there's is that Snopes do to personally
approve the fives no now that I went
inspection a post falsely link found
she's wife to FDA vaccine no the Dr
fauci's wife Reuters no I want to know
if and they're not just is the head of
U.S and food and yeah they're not even
so if you go on Snopes and you type in
fauci
uh uh uh uh fauci that's insane wife
um
did Biden since
yeah I mean look they if they don't even
have a story on it you know that's even
a bigger concern that they're not even
addressing it anyways I don't know I
think I think it's not good protocol in
the company for the HR to be the wife
and the guys making all the decisions
especially when you and I taxpayers are
paying for it you know if you're sitting
there saying what's wrong with that
again you're part of the problem yeah I
agree 100 like and now but and I said
this the other day ethics what do you
like she's it's not even that it's like
I said this the other day now
everybody's like with Elon with the
Twitter with the dumps and everything is
out we know now it's like hey we got you
it's like The Wizard of Oz Pat the
curtains open now we see oh look at what
you what you [__] were doing and now
nothing's gonna happen the Republicans
are going to take the house what are
they gonna do they're gonna sit them
down in the chair Congress they're all
going to yell the Democrats are going to
stick up for them because they use him
to bring in their [__] the Republicans
are just gonna bark my butt nothing will
happen he's gonna walk free because Adam
you nailed it his Alliance is bro he's
Untouchable yeah Untouchable bro his
wife is HR yeah that's right that's like
the uh The Wizard of Oz at the end of
the day he's married to the chief of
police you're good dude yeah don't worry
about it yeah nothing's gonna happen Pat
you're an odds guy obviously I don't I
think it's fair to say
that you're not a fan of fauci fair
I'm not a fan of anybody that puts Force
got it yeah you're an odds guy I'm I you
know I like to reference Vegas for odds
what are the odds that fauci will face
any penalties criminals uh uh monetarily
anything exactly feet fines any and he
finds criminal anything like that fauci
faces any of that less than five percent
oh you're even putting it that high yeah
less than five percent less than five is
I mean
when you when you're a bureaucrat like
like uh fauci is and you've been around
for how many presidencies seven he's
been around he's been around for a long
time my question is this like do they
basically sit you down and say Hey
listen what you whatever we want you to
do you're because you're the voice
you're the head doctor
of the NIH whatever you say is set in
stone you do this and no matter what
you're gonna you're never gonna see one
day inside of a jail cell do you think
that that conversation happens or is
just an unsaid Untold thing where
they're just like hey bro you're a
Democrat we we got you just don't ever F
us up you know I mean do you think that
conversation happens Pat with him with
him no you don't think so by the way
here's here's what I do think uh what I
do think will happen when you and I are
62 years old okay we're going to be at
the movie theaters watching a movie
called Avatar 30. covet 19. you know
that's what the movie's going to be
called no joke I'm telling you okay he's
gonna be dead and someone's gonna have
the courage to make a movie on some kind
of a streamlined service that's you know
on the right and we're gonna sit there
and we're going to watch everything
about Fouch and you're gonna say get the
hell out of here
and and most people are gonna be like ah
who cares life moves on yeah it was 20
years ago I don't give a [__] about this
but some of us are going to care about
it like for example Argo when I watched
the movie Argo with Ben Affleck there's
a scene where they're going to the
Embassy and they're getting them out my
dad watched that movie emotional because
his sister was in the embassy when they
came in and she left and married a
marine or some soldier in the U.S she
left she went to Ohio yeah she left the
entire my dad's like I had to go pick
her up and I have to do this and I have
to do that so but it took 30 something
years until CIA was able to make the
movie Argo so maybe we're gonna see the
I said 62 years old I think we're going
to be 74 years old when we see that
movie you know how old she is now 81 I
think he's like 82. yeah I I just I will
find it ironic does it is sort of some
comedy some satire here 15 years from
now Anthony fauci is 97 years old and he
uh he's got diabetes he's got prostate
cancer he's got some heart issues he's
got a harder arrhythmia he's got all
these pre-existing conditions but he'll
die of covid oh my God that'd be so
great
that would be polite
what would be funny is if the
prescriptions come out saying he took
Ivermectin that's yeah that's even
better oh my God I think that's hard
that's the real story and it's but it's
like Pat it's like and and again during
the moment during all the like all the
bias all the media all the everything
they got away with so much now it's like
it's so far away people are like man we
got other we got other [__] to worry
about we got other fish to fry who gives
a [__] Tay is Tay is sex trafficking
whatever they look I know people in
California Pat in Glendale California
that were putting fauci's uh picture on
you know those lawn yeah like I'm like
who the he's not running for president
he's just a little guy that's ahead of
the NIH they were worshiping this guy
praising him yeah I mean even people
that are uh that are putting um
zielinski on their phone yeah what do
you mean is a gangster boy he came in in
like a sweater pajamas with a flag
tongue down Nancy Pelosi and he left bro
that guy's a gangster it's gonna be yeah
by the way a lot of people if you think
about it have stayed quiet a little too
long on this topic here a lot of people
have been very quiet not saying anything
um elon's tweet just kind of shows he's
responding a little bit because there's
nobody that talks about Matrix more than
one guy yeah one guy's the guy that
talks about Matrix I don't know how many
Lawrence Fishburne by the way you know
what was the first you know was the
first time I watched Matrix on the way
to interview him yeah
I know I know this and and I'm and I'm
like I'm a guy that understands the
whole concept of it but the first time I
ever watched Matrix when I'm like this
guy likes the movie so much let me watch
it on the way too you're a pretty big
guy I can't believe you I've never
watched I've tried watching Matrix so
many freaking times how'd you like it
first 30 minutes drives me insane it's
too slow movie starts too slow I lose it
and but I I watched through go ahead
Andrew Tate's Twitter account retweet
tweeted the Elon Musk meeting that we
read earlier about an hour ago yeah I
saw that about that what if I told you
yeah I'm telling you right now we got to
get Keanu Reeves on this part please can
we find something right now Keanu Reeves
if you're listening this I know you're a
big fan of the podcast is he yeah of
course what why wouldn't he makes what
are you talking about dude number one
business podcast in the world hello
business let's talk about doing
something with the Matrix Keanu I would
love to that'd be great to talk to that
guy he's a g every every every video I
see of him either on the train in New
York giving people his seat he's a he's
a g bro I really like him because he
knows about the Matrix he gets it any
other stories before we wrap up you're
right I don't know you have anything
else
um here's what I will say we thought
that yesterday uh was gonna be the last
podcast of the Year this is now turned I
think this is the last podcast of the
year I've been thinking us having to do
another emergency tomorrow Elon Musk got
arrested I don't know that's going to be
that's gonna be a thing
um but I will say I know there's a how
many people are are live with us right
now should I have 20. okay 20. about 20
000 almost hi guys guys thank you we do
this every Tuesday Thursday if you have
not subscribed to pbd podcast or
valuetainment we'd appreciate
a sub oh please this is what we do
around here please we appreciate you
anyways having said that gank for those
that tuned in came in have a great
weekend Happy New Year to you have a
blast and we'll do this again next week
if something crazy happens like such as
Kate messages me saying do you want to
do a live together if we get a call like
that we may do an emergency podcast
again but aside from that wish everybody
a Happy New Year take care everybody
bye-bye bye-bye